welcome to this video playing cross
shock from from the UK and down it's a
con variation 53 isn't this interesting
now with yes and then up with a 5 hmm I
thought the song would be a good line
for black isn't this the case with h5
and and stuff nice form something like
that maybe I'm I'm confusing lines here
but thought this this kind of setup
would be good for black or let's say
let's say leads to two good play not
necessarily meaning up like is winning
or anything ok so I can win the exchange
should i do that i guess so so I forgot
that he's got this immediate move mmm
yes at the chart I just thought okay
I'll play Bishop e6 and what the heck I
doesn't really have anything going here
and now after move the bishop he's got a
six immediately hmm so Bishop deform
maybe e6 we should be five he can take
and Wynonna seven great maybe I need to
do that him
try to get this Bishop out of this
diagonal if he takes on f2 I take f4
takes g5 I play Bishop g4 and will
capture only five I hope that this is
working yeah a bit of a shame I mean I
didn't need to take the exchange I could
just take a five and have a good
position and don't have any trouble at
all and now i am in trouble hmm i wait a
half Bishop g4 i completely forgot about
that this is important to at least
temporarily protect the poem okay is
going to go Queen g3 I guess maybe I can
play walk age six then
can you need to move it what else yeah
my king I cannot castle long absolutely
not
yeah I don't really think this should be
should be a to grade for white he's got
play but he still has got completely
dead piece on d3 and this night isn't
particularly great as well the night can
be activated maybe with 92 or something
but the bishop here is just just a piece
of piece of dead wood so to say yeah but
still how to how to get their pieces
into play
yeah I need to I need to play with
Bishop e7 at some point I think it's
unavoidable I need to challenge this
bishop otherwise I have no way to ever
get the rook into play I need to reckon
with the idea to play Bishop e6 Bishop
d7 and even giving up the h-bomb it's so
it's it's I think simply mandatory to
get them to get the look into play and
get castle long
yeah an interesting move
ok trying to play Queen g4 maybe qui g4
Queen g6 something like that hmm okay
Bishop to e7 let's look at this is there
some discovery because of seven I don't
I don't see any and I'm beat down the
clock
yeah he's got two pawns for the exchange
though he's got decent material
compensation anyway takes takes Queen f7
is queenie five
try to get play against g2
activating the room or activating in
general he must be must be okay what is
he doing him edge ho I don't don't see
the point it's g2 I made on g2
maybe you wanted to give the check out
more slip check
Queen therefore I can do can take it so
might resign yeah probably just made a
mouse sleep here with Queenie five I
guess the position looks completely
unclear to me at the computer likes
black but it's uh it's just it just
super complicated everything anything
can happen this is ok we wanted to get
the check I'm sure ok I saw that this
was saying what i thought okay i need to
activate pieces of the queen is active
here maybe Rupert III or something yeah
this looks good yeah I somehow I managed
to untangle him and I think white had
had a really good position around here
this system at least it looked very
tricky the computer I think also likes
white knight g3 here and tending
probably hear that is very strong after
that look at this and black gets
destroyed yeah I'm in very bad shape
after night g3 after h3 you know still
93-yard IAM here the worst is over yeah
i'm i simply i forgot about queena three
I don't need to do this really here I
have other moves I can for example I can
just take here with a good position
enjoying this night outpost I have
possible developed mattia can put the
bishop only six and also can let's say
oops now this is too much I can
strengthen e5 with the bishop if I want
and there should be six and possibly
long castles this is just just fine I
mean black has some good
in here and this is the jamming but I
forgot about I haven't forgot about the
possibility of e six computers
completely unfazed again it thinks that
this is good for black maybe yeah I
guess I just saw ghosts IAM can just
this is this is really insane I can't do
that I was only thinking that this is
not working of course you can take and
check take here but this isn't some such
a problem check yeah this is actually
quite safe I even could castle shot yeah
I mean this is not lost or anything yeah
this I should have done this also means
that taking the exchange was was okay
yeah this is probably a bad for black
alright thanks for watching